what excites me about this course is the
opportunity to work with individuals who
are either creating their own businesses
or launching important new investment
projects within their firms
and often individuals in this position
need to rely on outside financial
experts to understand
the financial consequences of the
decisions that they're making
but what i hope to convey in this course
is that the basic tools of finance are
really relatively straightforward
and that by gaining an understanding of
those tools managers will be empowered
both in terms of how they manage their
projects they'll become better investors
and more successful entrepreneurs
so in this course we're going to cover
the main tools of financial valuation
how do we look at an investment
opportunity or a project and understand
the value that it creates the risks that
are inherent in it
how to then manage that project better
and make optimal trade-offs
i hope that students take away from this
course a set of skills that they can use
throughout their professional careers as
well as even in their personal lives
when they're thinking about financial
decisions that they confront
and use those tools to make better more
informed decisions
in a variety of circumstances
as in many things in life being a
successful entrepreneur
really requires a great application of
the old 80 20 rule
that is you know focusing your time on
the 20 of things that really matter
and one of the benefits of this course
is that we're going to develop the
financial tools that allow you to
understand
those 20 of the decisions that are
really going to impact the value of a
project or investment decision that
you're making